as the u.s struggles to contain the
coronavirus there are growing concerns
about a possible new spike in europe
many of those cases are tied to
reopenings elizabeth palmer reports from
london where new travel restrictions
are in place there as soon as travel
restrictions eased in mid-june
europeans flocked to sunny spain a month
on the number of coveted cases there has
quadrupled
that's the biggest uptick but there are
spikes in france
germany and belgium too i'm afraid you
are starting to see
in some places the signs of a second
wave of the pandemic and we all remember
what happened last time the uk
government
abruptly announced a two-week quarantine
for britons returning from spain
it doesn't seem to be a consistent
strategy i don't think anybody knows
what they're doing
in germany public health officials have
set up free
covered testing stations at airports
strict lockdowns this spring left some
of the most famous tourist sites in the
world
eerily deserted but life has begun to
trickle back
another lockdown brought on by a second
wave of covid would be devastating
and unnecessary says professor david
hayman
you wouldn't be recommending a complete
shutdown
of travel in europe no i wouldn't be i
think we need liz to begin to
understand how to travel safely
and we begin we need to begin to get
back to normal
but normal doesn't mean going on
vacation to forget the pandemic
to flatten europe's worrying covert
spikes
tourists can expect enforced social
distancing
local curfews lots of testing
and everywhere masks even at the beach
for cbs this morning i'm elizabeth
palmer in london